[Music]  honestly I'm gonna cry I'm gonna cry  [Music]  finally find out what this animal is all  about everybody excited  this is honestly amazing this is the  best bagger I think of hatch  this year let's bag I think I've had  that was worth waiting like three hours  for absolutely love it actually bought  one after waiting for such a long time I  wanted to God I did miss it it's no five  guys it's pretty good I had a lot of  burgers  I have one of these coins which are  really really unusual you only get them  the foot when they open a new store the  first in line gets one of these and I  showed up here today without being able  to get here in the queue early enough  they took one look at the coin and said  you're good for a burger